مع تحذيرا صحيا مهم لكل من يتناول كوب
قهوه او يحتسي الشاي وهو يتابعنا الان
اليكم هذا التحذير اذا اضفت اي نوع من
المحليات الصناعيه البديله للسكر الافضل
ان تحضر وربما ان تتوقف عن استخدامنا
بالفعل منظمه الصحه العالميه مشاهدينا
اعلنت في بيان رسمي ان الاستخدام طويل
الامد لبدائل السكر الصناعيه قد يؤدي الى
الاصابات بازمه قلبيه وايضا امراض
مزخره كالسكري كما وضحت بان المحليات
البديله لا تساعد في تقليل دهون الجسم على
المدى الطويل كما هو شائع ونصحت بتقليل
السكر بشكل عام في نظامنا الغذائي
مشاهدينا
بتعرفي عدد لو انه العالم اللي اكتشف
السكرين اتبع تعليمات النظافه وغسل ايديه
قبل مغادره المختبر لكان العالم بدون اقدم
تحليه اصطناعيه قصه غريبه عجيبه قصه
السكرين تبدا من مختبرات جماعه عام 1878
عندما كان عالم الكيمياء الروسي الالماني
قسطنطين يقوم بعده ابحاث تخص مركبات قطران
الفحم الكيميائيه
في احدى الليالي عامل العالم لوقت المتاخر
وشعر بالجوع وترك المختبر وذهب لتناول
الطعام تجاهل غسل يديه قام فقط بمسحها
بمنديل وبدا في الاكل
العالم لاحظ حينها طعما كثيرا الحلاوه في
الاكل في الوقت الذي لم يكن يحتوي الاكل
على السكر فاستنتج ان المواد التي بقيت
عالقه في يديه من قطران الفحم هي التي
اعطت الطعام هذا المذاق الحلو بحث عن هذه
الماده وبعد عده اختبارات اخترع ماده
السكرين التي تقدر حلاوتها اضعاف حلاوه
السكر العادي حصل على براءه اختراع بديل
السكر الذي اختار له اسم السكري عام 1884
واعتمدته الشركات المنتجه للمواد الغذائيه
والمشروبات قليله السعرات الحراريه وكذلك
شركات الادويه ابتداء من سنه 19
07 شكرا شكرا شكرا
على كل حال
احنا سالنا الناس مشاهدينا في مصر ما اذا
كانوا بيستخدموا السكر او بديل السكر وليش
خلينا نست
[موسيقى]
هو السكر كويس انا بعشق السكر لا ده كان
كنت في الشغل قبل كده كنت بشوف حاجه اشرب
بها زي نسكافيه وحاجه زي كده في السكر ما
لقيتهوش قمت واخد علبه كده
في النسكافيه بس دي الحلقه الوحيده بس
لا هو السكر بس استخدمه بديل السكر قبل
كده اه كان السكر دايت يعني مثلا بدل ما
اشرب الشاي ثلاثه مثلا اثنين
حاجات كثيره قوي اشربها من غير سكر احسن
لو لقيت سكر دايت استخدمه احسن من السكر
العادي عشان بيبقى له اضرار كتير قوي
[موسيقى]
يعني نفسها ان انا اتخن فيعني انا بجيب
فطائر سكر اهو عشان نرد امي اكيد بستخدم
سكر كل يوم تقريبا بس بحاول اقلل منه على
قد ما اقدر احاول اقلل منه استخدم البدائل
بتاعته زي العسل زي سكر الدايت اي حاجه
بحكولها من غير سكر على قد ما اقدر
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا وعادل هناك ثلاث دول عربيه
من اكثر الدول اصابه بالسكري ومنهم للاسف
بلدك انت يعادل الكويت مستويات السمنه
والسكر مرتفع جدا
للاسف عندنا ايضا في باكستان هي المرتبه
الاولى 31% تقريبا من السكان هذا رقم كبير
ومغول فيه بالكويت اكيد المرتبه الثانيه
كانت بحدود 25
[موسيقى]
بالمئه ونارو وهي جزيره صغيره في المحيط
الهادي حلت ثالثه بحوالي
24% ايضا كاليدونيا الجديده او كاليدونيا
الجديده كما تسمى هي الرابعه بنسبه
23.40% عنا ايضا جزر ماريانا الشماليه وهي
تاتي في المرتبه الخامسه جزر مارشل
بنسبه 23% يعني الكثير من الجزر على ما
يبدو عليها الكلام موريشيوس تاتي في
المرتبه طبعا السابع مصر في المرتبه
الثامنه بنسبه 21% يعني في اكثر من عشرين
مليون شخص في مصر يعانون من السكري جزر
سليمان تاتي في المرتبه التاسعه بنسبه 20%
طبعا خلونا بس نوضح بانه ترى على فكره
يعني حتى لو هي نسبه وتناسب قد يكون عدد
السكان ثلاثه مليون ولكن نسبه المصابين
25% منهم عاليه جدا بينما مصر مثلا 100
مليون عشرين بالمئه فقط منهم مصابين
فبالتالي
اصلا قديش في دعوات هلا للاقلاع عن السكر
وقف السكر بشكل كامل مع انه احنا بنحكي عن
المحليات
ويعني في بيكون في نوع من انواع المعجزه
اللي بتحصل بالجسم مجرد ما الانسان يوقف
سكر تخيل يعني
اول صحه القلب صحه البشره في عندك كمان
المفاصل كل اشي كل اشي بصير صحي اكثر حلو
ما اقدر الكاكاو بدون سكر يلا
من بيروت تنضم الينا استاذ مساعد في
الجامعه الامريكيه في هندسه صناعه المواد
الغذائيه والزراعيه الدكتوراه كريستال
الاسكندر دكتوره صباح الخير
صباح الخير يعني خليني اسال اول شيء بانه
اليوم احنا لا نستطيع ان نستغني عن السكر
حتى انه البعض بيقول انه خمسه مليجرام هي
فقط الكميه الكافيه لنا في كل اليوم انه
من كل المواد اللي احنا نتناولها
يعني يبدو لا شيء هي اقل من نصف ملعقه شاي
او غيره
صحيح
15 ملغم
من السكر يعني اقصد انه
الرقم غير معقول اني انا اتخلى عن السكر
بكل هذه الطريقه لانه جسمي فقط يحتاج وين
نذهب بكل هذه الصناعات
هلا هو بالمبدا في عنا كتير بديل
طبيعيه فينا نستعملها لحتى نستنى فيها
المواد الغذائيه ومنها العسل ومنها
الفواكه مثل البلح
البنانا بس تكون مستويه بتكون طعمتها سكر
ففي عنا كتير بدائل طبيعيه بنقدر نستعملها
او فينا نستعمل السكر بالسكر الطبيعي كل
شيء طبيعي يعني
بالحدود جالس سامحت لنا فيها المنظمه
العالميه طيب في كتير
دكتوره في كتير ناس بفضلوا طبعا عشان
الدايت والحميه الغذائيه وشكل الجسم
الجميل بفضلوا انه ما يستخدموا السكر
يستخدموا المحليات هلا الدراسه اللي احنا
كنا عم نحكي عنها والمعلومات بتتحدث عن
انه هاي المحليات الصناعيه السيئه جدا
للجسم مش بس انه هي ما بتساعد على انقاص
الوزن وكل ذلك حتى لو ما كان فيها سعرات
حراريه ولكن ايضا هي بتزيد عمليه الاكسده
في الجسم يعني ممكن ممكن تؤدي لامراض اخرى
تساهم في اصابتنا بامراض اخرى مثل السرطان
شو حقيقه هذا الموضوع قديش سيئه هي وقد
لازم ننتبه منها
هلا بالمطلق كل شيء هو صناعي اكيد بكون
منه منيح للجسم كل شيء طبيعي هو احسن
للجسم الدراسه يلي عملتها المنظمه
العالميه كنت عم بقراها قبل ما اجي بتقول
انه
هي الفوايد تبع المحليات الصناعيه فوائدها
بس على
فتره كتير قصيره لانه نحن عم نخفف من نسبه
السكر تنقدر نخسر من الوزن بس الاشخاص
اللي رح يعتمدوا كل حياتهم على استعمال
المحليات الصناعيه
باكلهن اليومي ويقطعوا السكر الطبيعي
ويقطعوا الفواكه على المدى البعيد عم
بيشوفوا انه هذا عم بياثر على سرطان
على السرطان عم بيعمل سرطان عم يعمل سكري
لانه عم بصير جسمنا ما بقى يتعرف على
الجلوكوز اللي هو السكر الطبيعي اللي نحن
مناخده مشان هيك بيقولوا انه المفضل انه
ما نكون كتير عم نستعملهم بحياتنا اذا حدا
مثلا والدراسه على فكره من عملت على اللي
هم عندهم سكري على الطبيعي
بس على الاشخاص العاديه مضبوط فمشان هيك
بينصحوا على طول انه مثل ما نحن صرنا عم
نخفف من الملح خلينا كمان نخففها من السكر
طيب اليوم اليوم الناس ربما تاخذ المحليات
طيب هناك نبته
انا بستعمل ستيفيا كمان اما انا لا ما احب
انا احب كل شيء غير صحي طيب هل ستيفيا
اليوم تغنينا عن السكر هل هي ايضا من ضمن
المحليات تدخل تدخل في هذه الدائره انه
كثره استخدامها قد يضر الجسم
نبته طبيعيه بس لنحصل على السكر من
الاستيفيا هو بيتحول بالمختبر او بالمعمل
لحتى يطلع لنا هالباودر يلي نحن بنستعمله
كمحلفه من ضمن السكريات الغير طبيعيه
فكمان كثره الاستيفيا مثل كثره الاسبرتام
وغيرها
بتعمل بنفس بنفس سوق المحليات الصناعيه
اعتذر لازم يكون منيح شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتوره كريستال اسكندر
المتخصصه استاذ مساعد في الجامعه
الامريكيه في بيروت في هندسه صناعه المواد
الغذائيه ان شاء الله ايضا ينحلها الدايت
اي شيء دايت مشروبات الغازيه العاديه
والدايت الناس تذهب الى الدايت انه والله
نخفف
حتى لا اكون انا يعني شخص افتي فانه يعني
انا
ما بدي استعمل سكر وما بدي عمل محليات
صناعيه وكان هذا البديل الافضل بس على ما
يبدو كل اشي باعتدال كل شيء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات